[Music]
welcome to SEC 2-1-1 my name is Rina Ned
Kearney I'm the product lead for
security and analytics on G suite today
we are going to have with us a couple of
my colleagues Panos as well as Mitch who
are going to help us and then also a
really cool customer story with Joey so
I'm very excited about this session
before we dive deep let's start by
understanding why this area is important
and why it matters Google recently did a
study with over 4,000 customers that
told us that security even today across
vendors is a number one barrier to move
to moving to cloud to upgrading to the
cloud right and we also found out that
irrespective of Geo's consistently
security shows up as one of the top
three needs along with things like
reliability that they care about so
that's why for us security and privacy
is a huge area of focus and why is this
really so difficult
first of all companies are rapidly
moving to the cloud as you can imagine
they're using more and more applications
and more devices I read some stats
somewhere that it was about 1,400
services per large company that they're
using so you can imagine it's really
hard to manage all these services
secondly there's constant issues with
updating patches and such with your
legacy systems and then the security
attacks are on the rise so if you
combine all of these together managing
your environment is really very
challenging so today we are going to
look at what we are doing both in chrome
as well as in G suite to help you manage
this better before we go down that path
I want to call upon an expert panels
Mavro mattis is an engineering director
at Google cloud
he runs the Google cloud Safe Browsing
team and he's worked at Google on
identifying fishing and
sites for over 13 years his papers on
phishing and Malware have over 2,000
citations so at Google we just basically
call him an underachiever Panos thanks
Reena
so serena mentioned I'm the engineering
director for Google Safe Browsing which
is a group of teams at Google that
fights phishing and malware across the
web email as well as our platforms I
actually joined in the Safe Browsing
team as an engineer in 2006 so I was
able to see the threat landscape as well
as our defenses evolve all those years
so today I'm excited to share some of
those trends with you for over ten years
and for 10 years before that Google has
been doing one thing really well which
is to crawl the web right what our team
does is crawl the web looking for bad
sites here we present how many new
malware sites we detect each week in the
blue line and how many new phishing
sites we detect each week again in the
red line and this goes back all the way
since 2009 so first with the good news
is the exploit based malware has been
dropping particularly since 2016 the
primary reason for that has been the
security work that was that was done by
the awesome chrome team over the last
decade that made browsers really more
secure against exploits features like
automatic updates and some boxing of the
rendering engine have basically made
these attacks extremely hard the I wish
I could say the same for fishing but as
you can see fishing has actually grown
compared to ten years ago we still
detect over 30,000 new fishing domains
each week and actually the previous
graph doesn't show the full picture the
malware exploits have dropped but power
is still around and malware still finds
its way to users it just uses a
different method of delivery it asks the
user to download and run the file
themselves
last year we showed twice as many
download warnings in Chrome as in 2016
even when we look at software downloads
from Chrome enterprise users 1/2 of a
percent of every file download that
could be carrying an application or
other software is flagged by Google Safe
Browsing every single day talking about
scale and scale and volume of attacks
Gmail detects and protects Google users
from over a hundred million phishing
emails each day when we look back at our
defenses against these threats over the
last 10 years we have learned a few
lessons sharing them today because I
think they can be helpful if you're
either building your own defenses or
choosing a platform to partner with that
comes with those defenses built in the
first lesson we learn is a very often
the cost of defenses can be
disproportionately higher than the cost
of attacks you can imagine why that's a
problem to give you an example and add
some color to that evading a classifier
can be done very easily for example you
experiment change your email a few times
change the file a few times until it's
no longer detected it goes through if on
the other hand you're on the defense
side and your job is to build a
classifier that will be evasion
resistant to every past and every future
attack that has ever been created and
will be created you should not take that
job it is an np-hard problem proven by
academia and anyone in the industry will
tell you that yes
that's not possible plus the more target
that the attack is the more expensive it
is to defend against it high volume
attacks they even though they can reach
a lot of people they actually carry a
very loud signal with them which is like
their volume so defenders can use volume
to prioritize and
defend against these attacks low-volume
attacks on the other on the other side
such as spearfishing or targeted malware
they tend to fly under the radar and to
build classifiers that catch those gets
expensive more and more expensive
machine learning is extremely important
in our industry and specifically for
security especially in this space it can
make a big difference in reducing for
example our time to react to changes
automatically this allows us to build
the more the most evasion it resistant
engines we can however one thing that we
found to be true and we've been using
machine learning since 2008 to
classifies both phishing and now we're
on the web is that we really need to
invest in the training data quality what
we call ground truth which is the both
the labels and the data itself the
freshness of the data all of that me
goes into the model quality and so the
lesson here was that you really need to
invest in the ongoing process of
maintaining the quality of the data
ninety ninety five percent of your
effort will go into that as opposed to
picking the latest and greatest ml
algorithm user education or employee
training is something that is common and
it can be useful it can reduce the
likelihood that a particular user may
click on a particular phishing link in
our experience this does not solve the
problem if you think about how training
is delivered often to employees we send
them a very original email then we ask
them to click on a link then they go
through some kind of authentication
dance and they probably enter their
corporate password on a site they've
never seen before only to land on a page
that tells them never to click on emails
and never to enter their corporate
password on a site they've never seen
before
and then he tries to explain to them how
to pass URLs with their eyes right so
you need to find the third slash and
then go back to dots sometimes three
dots and then that's the domain you're
on and so URLs were built for computers
and even computers have trouble parsing
URLs sometimes how can we expect let's
say a nurse that is finishing their
shift to be able to determine if a
phishing link is coming from a trusted
source or if the domain is actually
valid in general what we found is that
we're working with the very old in open
ecosystems the web email desktop
operating systems this have been so
incredibly successful everyone uses them
every day because they were open so we
need to do two things first work with
these up with these platforms we can't
just dream of the future and ignore the
product the present but we also want to
build the platforms of the future that
have security built into them that's
pretty much our strategy in in in the
space for building the best and fastest
reactive reactive and proactive
detections on the platforms that our
users are on our best hope is to
leverage our end-to-end visibility for
web and email as well as Google scale to
produce to protect the platforms our
users are currently using next we want
to build the next generation of
platforms which are actually designed
with security in mind I'll give an
example a very quick example of how we
leverage your visibility to protect
users on the web and email some Chrome
users opt into sharing security related
threat data with Google when chrome
detects something suspicious such as
typing your password on a website that
you've never seen been before Google is
able to quickly classify these sites
this could be brand new phishing sites
that no one has ever seen before if they
are confirmed then we can push that data
to Gmail and Gmail will filter that
emails
that contain those links before they
reach the users in books so to summarize
I've shared the current threat landscape
as from Google's unique vantage point
I've shared some of the lessons we
learned while building defenses against
them and how critical our end-to-end
visibility has been now I'm going to
pass back to Rena share how G suite and
chrome take advantage of these
technologies and provide additional
security features to help you protect
your employees and your users Thank You
Panos that was insightful with the
advances in malware and phishing
detection we believe that a truly cloud
native solution like G suite and Chrome
enterprise can help you secure your
company better it can improve your
company's security posture we believe
that we also don't want to force fit a
solution on our customers we want to be
able to meet them where they are
so today along with data that panel
shared and some of the insights and
lessons learned I'm going to share with
you some of the defenses that we have to
help you in your journey to the cloud a
simple way to think about our defenses
in G speed is that we want them to be
proactive intelligent compliant and
simple that's kind of dive deep into
each of these very quickly so proactive
the admins that manage these large
corporations are really busy and cyber
security skills are very hard to come by
so what we want to try to do is without
the admin having to do anything at all
we have proactive defenses in place so
things like polymorphic malware things
like being able to detect ransomware
that a panel talked about we're very
proud of our record of security on Gmail
when you think about intelligence we
really think about how to bring better
machine learning insights to be able to
show you all of these alerts together
and easier in one spot our alert Center
allows admins to manage these alerts in
in one spot and take actions on these
alerts last year we announced the G
speed security center and I think it's
useful to dive into that for a second
the G speed security center helps an
admin go from prevention detection and
remediation of all of your security
issues so first of all before you do
anything like I said in one spot you get
a complete view of your organization's
security picture we also show you a
single page where we give you all of G
suite security settings in one spot and
we also show you if you are deviating
from Google recommended best practices
in those security settings so that's
really helpful and then finally we have
the security investigation tool that
allows you to quickly remediate these
incidences but what about compliance
Google's practices and data handling
practices and such are audited by
third-party auditors across the globe so
when you come to Google we want to make
sure that we are helping you in your
compliance journey so for example the
ISO 27001 is a really good example of a
difficult to get certification so we are
here we're helping you on your
compliance journey and then what
commitments do we make to our customers
let's be clear about those first of all
no ads Google does not use your data in
je suis for ads purposes your data does
not get scanned for ads purposes at all
secondly you own your data so G speed
customers can take their data and leave
at any time through take out your apps
are accessible so we have SLA surround
that and finally you can delete your
data you stay in control of your own
data so these are commitments that we
make to our customers and security is
only as useful all these tools that we
make available to you are only as useful
as if people really begin to use these
tools and so we want to keep the
security tools really really simple for
our admins a couple of quick examples of
that the
one is that we have one console a single
console from which you can manage all of
your admin security and other including
your devices all together with this
centralized management console
we have people tell us that I used to
use this other system before and it had
14 different consoles and we really
believe in keeping things simple for the
admins because they're so overwhelmed
with this amount of data along with our
admin console 4G suite you also get
cloud identity which allows you to bring
in identity from other parties and we
have our mobile device management
solution which has seen a huge amount of
adoption with our customers both for
Android and for iOS a mobile device
management one of my favorite features
of our MDM is that it allows you to do
agentless monitoring of devices so what
that means is if someone adds your G
suite account to a device without them
having to download anything at all their
your account is protected and you get
access to enforce a password and to do
an account wipe not a full device swipe
right you don't want to be deleting
pictures you know baby pictures off of
somebody's phone but you can do just a G
suite account wipe off of their phone
the minute they add a G speed account to
the phone so that's sort of really
convenient very simple way to get
control over your corporate data data
regions so with with our geo dispersed
data centers G suite actually most of
our customers don't want to regionalize
their data they enjoy the read 'hi
redundancy and latency that G suite
provides however some of our customers
are under certain regulations for which
they cannot have their data leave EU or
leave the u.s. so for that we launched
data regions really simple adaptable so
if I create an account if I create a
document and I am based in EU and then I
transfer the ownership of that document
to say Panos who's based in the US
automatically the data regions policy
will adapt to that change in ownership
this year we're also including things
like backups and new G suite services
like forms and sites in our data regions
offering so I'm very excited about that
there's many customers that are using
both Chrome Enterprise as well as G
suite to manage their corporate IT we
have Veolia we have all pool and others
but instead of showing you just these
logos what I thought would be a really
good idea is for you to hear first-hand
from a customer what their journey was
like so for that I'm going to call Joey
Smith it's my great honor to invite Joey
on stage Joe is the vice president and
chief information security officer for
Snooks he was brought in to build a more
mature information security program in
the wake of a very public and
catastrophic reach he is joining us all
the way from st. Louis Missouri Joey
welcome
yeah as rena said my name is Joey Smith
I'm the vice president and chief
information security officer for schnook
markets and I've given this particular
presentation or a version of it in a
number of different settings and I got
to tell you this is the first time I've
ever done it in a movie theater and you
all look very comfortable so what I want
to talk you through is a bit about who
Chinooks is I've met a lot of different
folks over the last two days and so far
no one's known the company that I work
for and that just to us that just means
you're probably not from the st. Louis
area because Chinooks is very relevant
and large in the st. Louis area but we
don't have any any stores on the east or
west coast so let me go a bit into who
schnooks is and what it is that we're
doing and ultimately what led us to our
decision to move G suite and now further
as we explore what GCP can do for us as
a business but since I'm going to talk
about a public breach is Rena mentioned
I do always my attorneys ask that I open
and just let everyone know that these
opinions are mine they're not
representative of my employers this also
accounts for any employer I used to work
for I used to work for MasterCard and
they used to also have me say this
anytime we go up and talk about
merchants or any type of breach events
so with that being said I somehow now
the green light to go kind of give you
guys a bit of a behind the curtains view
of what happened to Chinooks and how we
ended up responding to that so first off
let me talk a bit about chinook markets
and in the industry that we're in in the
business that we do so chinook markets
has been around for about 79 years now
we're coming up on our 80th anniversary
we were founded in 1939 and we're a
third generation family-owned grocery
retailer we have at this point as of
about six months ago we had now about a
hundred and twenty stores across the
Metro st. Louis area and surrounding
states Missouri Indiana Iowa and
Wisconsin in Illinois we employ over
15,000 teammates across all those stores
we also have pharmacies in all of our
stores we're actually the 48th largest
food retailer in North America in the
country 17th largest privately held
grocery store more recently we've
launched a Chinooks rewards program a
mobile app where you can now shop and
get points for all your purchases and
then you can cash those points in for
money off of your current basket that's
going through that's been wildly
successful and we are on track in the
first and six to nine months here to
have over a million of our customers on
that platform so now we're getting more
and more data that we've never had
before about our customers what they
shop where they shop what they're buying
those types of things that we can
leverage tools like Google cloud
platform to draw some very very powerful
insights into how we can specifically
target those employees and give them
experiences that they're asking for one
of the things that attracted me to
schnooks was what it is that they do in
the communities that we serve so we're
very proud we we offer our customers
what we call an e scripps program this
is a program that you as a customer of
Chinooks can go in and you can set which
local charity you would like to donate a
certain percentage of your shop to so
this allows our customers to pick
organizations that are relevant to them
for example my wife and i we pick the
school that that our kids go to just
down the road from us and so a certain
percentage of what we spend at Chinooks
goes directly into the communities that
we serve so it's not necessarily this
big giant corporate initiative where you
know maybe it's the corporate company
has chosen United Way and while as a
customer I could choose United Way I
would rather put that more local
my community so we're very proud that we
donate more than two million dollars
annually to these types of programs
across all of the st. Louis and regions
that we operate in this is again one of
the things that that attracted me to
Chinooks because it's something that us
giving back really helps us understand
and put our customer first which is very
important to us so as ingrained into the
community as schnooks is and has
everyone that shops there can appreciate
that that they know that their money is
going to some non-for-profits that that
they appreciate and while we're all over
the map in st. Louis and as local as we
are like all of you in the audience we
also maintain a global security threat
and let me take you back through a bit
of our history and really going back to
the year 2013 this was the year that
semantics semantics named the year of
the mega breach I have some of these
numbers up here and I won't read them
out loud but you can see this was really
the gear that breeches really started to
hockey-stick now you look at some of
these numbers and compare them to the
numbers today and this is like really
nothing but this was the year that
information security was really put on
the map and chief information security
officers and cyber security teams
started to get a lot more attention they
weren't really in the back of the bus
anymore they were coming to the
forefront because all this stuff was
happening and at this time I was working
for MasterCard and we were doing
analytics on breach merchants because we
were able to see we were able to see the
fraud data and we could correlate that
to what we called a common point of
purchase and we could identify the
merchant that was ultimately bleeding
the credit card data merchants like
Target and Home Depot well this was
actually before Target and Home Depot
but this was this was that year wherever
the the hackers that were out in the
world started to recognize and realize
the vulnerabilities of merchant systems
and the lucrative nature of that
magnetic stripe data that goes through
those systems by March 2013 or I should
say really in December 2012 she fell
victim to one of these statistics and
little did the company know but in
December of 2012 a hacker had gained
unauthorized access to our systems put
some malware on our point-of-sale
systems and began ciphering credit
data out of our environment it was by
March of 2013 that there was an
incredible amount of media activity
around this the media plays note gives
no favors to merchants that are breached
and really loves to throw them under the
bus and it was something one of those
catastrophic moments in our company's
history that we weren't necessarily
prepared to respond to at the time so as
I think back again I was st. Louis as a
baseball town and the Carnales just
started and and like all good st. Louis
folks I was sitting on the couch one day
watching the st. Louis Cardinals play a
game it went to commercial break and the
first commercial that popped up was the
CEO Chinooks sitting on a chair suit and
tie on the edge of tears literally
taking commercial time out to apologize
to the entire city of st. Louis
I'm sorry st. Louis we lost your trust
we are committed to winning that trust
back it was unbelievable you don't see
that type of stuff today so the the
picture I'm trying to paint is this was
before there was really a playbook on
how to respond to these types of events
so was at this time we were just seeing
this incredible amount of negative
publicity in the news constant
front-page story of all the local st.
Louis networks running this we're
running commercials to apologize for
this event and we were absolutely
besides ourselves so as a consumer and
just a customer of Chinooks I was
absolutely floored and particularly as
somebody in the information security
field who had who has been dedicating
their career towards towards risk
mitigation and things to that nature I
couldn't believe the amount of press
that Chinooks was getting around this
event and again I go back to this was
before target this was before Home Depot
and you know oh my goodness Equifax puts
all of these numbers to shame but this
was something that really pushed the
company to the edge of edge of how are
we going to start to respond to this and
one of the things that was interesting
to me as I interviewed for the job as
their first named chief information
security officer was they made a
declaration and they told me we are
going to look at this event and we're
not going to let it define us we're
gonna allow this event to become our
finest hour we're going to learn from
this event and we're gonna use our
learnings to be able to go out into the
communities that we serve and further
like Google next for example and be able
to tell our story and talk
- whether it's our customers or other
folks in the IT insecurity field about
what we did and how we survived and how
we came out of this so let me tell you a
bit about that story and more
specifically given the theme of this
conference what we ended up doing from a
from a Google perspective so around this
time I ended up taking the job I began
to deploy a risk and threat based
security strategy where we were no
longer just focusing on compliance and
making sure we were PCI compliant or
HIPAA compliant and we began to hire a
team and move people internally to come
over to my group to really start to
identify threat and risk and look at our
security posture through those lens at
one point maybe about a year and a half
or so into my journey as the chief
information security officer there we
actually did have an event where a piece
of ransomware landed on one of our
internal servers and fortunately because
of some of the security controls that we
had been putting in place it didn't do
anything
our security controls detected it and it
did not install however it did breach
our perimeter it got in and it landed on
one of our servers Mike Kissel's on my
team he's the senior manager of endpoint
and cloud security Mike came into my
office that day after we looked at that
and we were kind of wiped out Brown said
thank God that that didn't install
because had it installed it would have
encrypted all of our unstructured data
which is where our Microsoft Exchange
Server sat in in that particular data
center and he came up to me and he asked
me this very serious question and this
was the question that was a key moment
in our decision as we started to look at
different ways to protect our data and
our customer data and he asked me this
you said are you confident Joey enough
in this detection response strategy that
we've been deploying are you confident
enough that you right now can walk into
our CEOs office mr. Chinooks office and
tell him that if a ransomware attack hit
our exchange server that he can fire you
and I was like well absolutely not we
just dodged this one bullet we were
lucky that our endpoint controls
actually detected that and stopped it so
no there'd be no way that I can tell you
that I would be confident enough to walk
in his office and say our change servers
can survive a ransomware attack there's
no way any less well I can tell you how
so well let's start talking so this is
the begin
the introduction of what Google can mean
for a retailer like Snooks so we began
to look at Google and we looked at it
obviously I was looking at it through
the lens of security and what do we gain
by moving some of our more valuable
corporate assets and data unstructured
data as well as email calendar and those
types of things into Google cloud under
the lens of security and looking at
what's their security posture look like
and what's the funding that they give to
their security teams and how do they do
encryption versus all those sames
questions on my side and it was a clear
winner that I can't put in the amount of
security budget or security stack that a
company like Google can a company that's
focused more so on security than a local
privately held retailer so after a lot
of collaboration with the different
business units and looking at it through
my lens and they began to look through
it through the lens of collaboration how
can we more effectively run store
operations and things to that nature all
the other senior leadership team at
Chinooks ended up making the decision
that gee suite was the right move to go
so I'm gonna talk now and this is where
I'll close on the three major learnings
that we have had and we've been on G
suite now for for right over two years
and what it is that we learned in this
rollout and some of the things that went
well actually I'll be very honest some
of the things that didn't go so well
and some of the things that we never
expected so first let's see what went
well for us we moved to Google like I
said two years ago and prior to doing
that I talked about some of the other
senior leaders that we engaged in this
move so it wasn't just something another
thing from Joey's team who's hearing the
word yes a lot because you know we come
off of a breach they're gonna let me
spend the money that we need to spend
help mitigate that risk let's get the
way in from some of the other business
units so we partnered with members of IT
infrastructure store operations digital
marking digital marketing legal asset
protection HR communication my group and
information security and created a
steering committee around this
initiative making sure that what Google
could offer us could also help solve
problems and allowed them to operate the
way that they're used to in potentially
even more effectively we started a tech
team we issued a very robust training
program around that
one of the things that I loved so much
about Google was literally overnight
once we turned Google G sweet on I was
able to roll out two-factor
authentication within just a click of a
button to our end-users it was
absolutely amazing I can't talk about
the importance of two-factor
authentication enough from a security
perspective Google lets me lets us do
that seemed absolutely seamlessly it was
a beautiful thing particularly when you
look at some of the other offerings of
how much they cost and how much they
cost to deploy two-factor just being
included is is is impressive by Google I
think Google for that for sure the
immediate collaboration that we began to
see across the stores I tell the story
of we had a older lady store manager or
in her job every Monday morning was to
take an excel sheet and and put all of
the pnls across all the stores that were
in her division so that's maybe like 25
stores so she would get her store and
then 24 other email attachments of the
same stupid excel file with their stupid
what not there with their pls in and
she'd have to open every single one you
know control see their data then go to
the other one and control the copy paste
copy paste 24 other times into a master
file save it attach it send it up the
chain of command to the division manager
who would then look at it and have all
that data it was this absolutely
ridiculous and it says very Microsoft D
things way to do things
well once we rolled out Google G suite
it was one shared sheet across that
entire division they can now do him on
their mobile devices they can update and
the coolest one of the coolest quotes
that I got back from that group was that
now I can do this what used to take me
20 30 40 minutes every Monday morning I
can do in five minutes on my phone on
the sales floor with my customers where
I need to be not upstairs off of the
sales floor and and the the most
beautiful part of that story was these
weren't technical teammates these are
just teammates that were able to figure
out this collaboration tool and start
using it to to get some of the more busy
work type stuff out of the way in a
collaborative format moving on here's
some of the things that fail I talked
about two factors so we are a proud
Union employer in the st. Louis area the
union does have contracts about you're
not allowed to use Coar anything
corporate on my personal cell phone so
wow you you probably
argue I think US tech minded people in
the crowd here today we could probably
argue that with google authenticator
you're not actually doing any corporate
data we're not calling your AT&T or
Verizon we're not charging you for text
messages giving those but we couldn't
push out two-factor to their personal
devices and that was okay so we were
able to solve that through the UB keys
that that we talked about a bit for
anti-phishing and things like that so we
can still have the two-factor but it
wasn't as easy and wasn't something that
we necessarily considered was the union
aspect of that limited number of people
that can get into a shared inbox has
been a bit of a challenge for us we're
in a general inbox in Google you can
share it with I think it's like 20-25
people well our stores have sometimes
over a hundred teammates so basically
we're left with a store managers to pick
their favorite 25 and those are the ones
I have access to that store inbox that's
an easy fix something that we've you
know Google about and very simple for
them to be able to up that we're just
waiting for that that new release let's
see executive admins are a hard group to
please so they schedule meetings and
it's different you know it's one of
those things we talk about change
management some of the things that we
did well was working with our partners
of ours at augusto to work through this
change management how do we address that
make sure you pay attention to your
executive admins they are the direct
line to your c-level employees and what
they say is what your C level employees
believe and if they have a bad time
scheduling an employment because they're
not used to something then ultimately
this incredible product can get a
negative connotation it's not always
fair so we did learn that we need to
spend a lot more time with our executive
admins they're not necessarily the most
technical people they love to listen
they love to partner with us but at the
end of the day they are very difficult
to please also with training we had a
really good training program we made it
very simple using the Google tools for
people to sign up we did video content
we recorded the meetings we did a lot of
the same things we're seeing here with
the keynotes where they were either
streamed live or you could watch the
video later and then ultimately was just
trying to get people hungry enough to go
seek out that training on their own is
also very difficult things that we never
expected it was surprisingly challenging
I was mostly excited about Google
obviously because of the security
winds that I get from the two-factor to
the encryption dated motion data at rest
data out of my environment but it was a
lot more difficult to get our end-users
excited about something that to them was
just simply perceived as a new calendar
and email tool and I say time and time
again whenever I talked to our teammates
that if we bought we did not buy Google
for calendar an email I really honestly
don't care that much about calendar eat
or email those things are relatively
commodity in my opinion it's all the
other tools that Google GC offers us
that empowers us as employees and
empowers us as a business Google or
email and calendar being part of that
but was amazingly challenging to get it
past the mind of what does Drive mean
and what how can I use hangouts versus
sending an email what does collaboration
and sheets Docs slides and those types
of things
really positive ROI on the reduction of
our spam filter that used to sit in
front of our exchange environment I know
we talked about a bit in a session about
what Google's doing in spam and it is
again just lights out better than any of
the competition that we had seen and we
and we did have a spam provider that we
had in front of our change environment
once we moved to Google G suite we saw
that that went quiet because Google was
already taking care of it and we were
able to sever our relationship with that
spam provider saving us a very very
significant amount of money annually on
that we just let Google take care of the
spam first now again all included as
part of the GP package I talked about
users technical knowledge or lack
thereof that's not something to
underestimate to us it's very easy you
know you click the blue button it says
sin and guess what it does it sends the
email that's not always as
understandable by some of our end users
and we were literally coaching them
through some of what we kind of take for
granted as technically minded folks so
there was there's a lot of lack of
technical knowledge and it probably is
more rooted in resistance to change
where you know we've had we've had funny
stories where people are very adamant
they don't want to get out of Excel so
so they won't go to sheets and the
reasons that we're hearing are just like
laughable where we
heard we heard a lady talk about I don't
want to move two sheets because I don't
trust the math we're like well two plus
two still equals four in sheets just
like it does in Excel so moving and help
moving that needle from a technical
perspective is also something that we
didn't expect and I talked about Excel
and how deep our love for Excel goes and
and that's very true we have a deep
spider web network of Excel files and I
imagine that probably most of you in
your businesses do as well Google does a
great job of in most cases transitioning
those Excel files to sheets and what we
ask our end-users is as you create new
content create an G suite and move
forward older stuff but we're moving
further and further away from Excel as
we're trying to lessen our dependency on
Microsoft but has definitely been the
challenge and and something that you
should definitely keep in mind as you
consider moving your business to G suite
so those are some high-level things went
well what failed and what we never
expected this was a decision that we
made in a post breach environment in
Google juice sweet has been a fantastic
decision from my perspective as the
information security officer to reduce
risk help us with threats stop spam stop
phishing attacks and it's been something
that I've been very proud to help lead
that way at Chinooks and it's been one
of those differentiating tools as we
look to continue to mitigate our attack
service and lessen our overall security
risk so that those types of events that
we incurred in 2012 and 2013 never
happened again for us so that's our
story I appreciate you guys listening to
me thank you google for having me out
here to share that andreen I'll hand it
back over to you to close this out Thank
You Joey
you know our mission is to really change
and make work better for as many people
as possible and so hearing stories like
what Joey did with his companies you
know I'm grading to G sweet it's really
heartwarming to hear so thank you for
sharing that story I'm gonna next run
through some quick launches what's new
this year and what we are launching and
then mitch is gonna show you a quick
demo and we'll close the session out
okay so first in our set of launches is
access transparency the blog just went
out but this is an exciting area for us
as customers even large customers that
you know in some areas compete with
Google move through G suite we want to
make sure that they're fully comfortable
with what G suite does and does not do
with their data we never access a
customer's data for anything other than
meeting our contractual obligations to
them sometimes for example when
customers call us for doing something
like technical support Googlers do need
to look at your data to help you
mitigate those issues but what we're
launching with access transparency is
that every single such access will be
logged and you will be able to file a
ticket if you have a question about why
someone accessed your data and this is
sort of industry-leading in terms of how
much transparency we're giving you for
every single clear text access by a
human being at Google so that's access
transparency for you the next one is to
collaborate on you know your security
journeys so what we have found is that
most large companies have a team of
admins that work together right so first
of all we are giving them the ability to
create automatic automated alerts to
take actions or mediate evacs ends on
any kind of alerts that they get and the
second thing is that when you work
together as a team of admins you may
have the way they collaborate together
is very archaic
and we're trying to build G suite style
collaboration the example that Joey just
gave right even in the admin security
journeys so for example I come in early
and I have an investigation that I am
looking at and then the next admin comes
in and they want to be able to follow
along I don't have to take screenshots
and then message them to them or email
them I can share the investigation as a
view only investigation and the other
admin can follow along this is going to
be a game changer for our admins because
no one's really thought about their user
journeys in this way so I'm very excited
about this we also want to provide
simple access anywhere you are so if you
are seeing there's a theme here right we
want the data to be secure but we do not
want security to get in the way of your
employees
as they look to be productive in their
day job so context-aware access is a
huge win in this area what this allows
you to do is that every single access
that is required for your apps or your
infrastructure is vetted specifically
for that access depending on where the
person is what kind of device they're
using and things like that there are
many signals that feed into it and so
that context of where access is also
launching in beta now and then we like I
said before for data regions we're
adding additional new products like
forms and sites and we will allow you to
store vote your primary data and backups
in the place that you want with that I'm
going to call Mitch crystal my colleague
to come and show you a demo of some of
these technologies medicine Thank You
Reena hello everyone so with the
increasing complexities that the
corporate environments are facing and
the ever-growing list of threats our
security professionals are really more
and more burdened so I want to show you
a couple of examples of products and
features that Google is rolling out in
order to provide you with tools that
make it easier to use provide
scalability and also offer best
practices on the security front can you
switch please the input thank you all
right within the security admin tool for
example you have the ability now to see
all of your security related settings on
a single page as it pertains to all of
the G suite settings so with that ease
of use we give you a very simple way of
seeing all of your security settings in
a single location and also follow along
to see what are the recommendations that
we provide for you to improve the
security setup or also give you the
ability to see that you've actually set
up all of the security related practices
that that we recommend
so depending on the settings you have a
very simple and scalable way to actually
view everything that's going on within
the resources that you provide again
this offers all the administrators a
single page to see all of your settings
save time and centrally manage all of
your security related settings in
addition to the resource settings we
also offer you the ability to manage
access via devices write more and more
people bring their own devices to the
corporate environment and you have to
control all of these devices in a
scaleable and easy-to-use fashion and
what we provide there is the ability to
do agent lists mobile device management
so if somebody shows up and brings their
device you have the ability and I'm
going to use here my own personal device
to connect for example to corporate
resources and automatically without me
having to install anything on my device
I show up within the device management
there's no software to push no approvals
to perform and I now as an administrator
have the ability to control that device
remotely so again offering you the ease
of use as well as scalability to handle
any kind of device setup that your users
may actually bring to the table and here
you can enforce all your policies as
Reena said earlier wipe the data that is
specifically pertaining to G suite or
just disconnect the device altogether
okay but within our environment you also
have to control access way beyond the
perimeter of your network right so these
days people access your corporate
resources in any kind of environment
inside of your corporate network outside
of your corporate network again with
various devices and until now they've
been very limited capabilities on
offering fine grains and easy-to-use
controls in those days basis so with
that I want to introduce to you a
product that we currently have in beta
which is the context-aware access that
allows you to manage how people are
accessing
your G suite resources with varying
levels of control so as I said the
product is currently in beta some of you
may already be familiar with it but in
this case for example a person that
accesses a drive resource you can enable
context to where a context aware access
and by providing that capability you
actually have the features where you can
manage access either by IP subnet device
policy or access level so depending on
the location of your users or the
devices that they use or the particular
access control it that you have
allocated to them they now can see
whether or not that particular user has
actually access inside of the network or
as well as outside of the network ok so
just in closing with these additional
tools that we provide you can see how
we're making it easier for you to
control your environment provide you a
lot more control as well as scale these
features with essentially an always-on
default protection thank you so to
summarize Google strengthened security
really comes from our scale Google
carries one-fourth of the Internet's
overall traffic with Android and chrome
as well as Google cloud platform were
able to see more and hence we are able
to build better machine learning models
were able to better use the scale to
protect our customers we're very focused
on the admin user journeys as they go
from prevention detection and
remediation of their security instance
incidences and I'm very grateful for
panels drawimage to be here today we're
all going to be waiting here if you
any questions please come back to us
afterwards with that thank you
[Music]